I think a lot about how the human
condition is is changing and how
technologies are enabling sort of what
we're gonna be I think that the two big
questions for Humanity are what is the
trajectory of intelligence and sentience
in other words like what's the point
and also like how do we get there
without killing each other or just just
all dying violently I think that there
should be UN sustainable development
goals for can humanity get on the same
page about what's after people and can
we figure out a way to have a non
arms-race global dynamic to get there
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sathyan we
are on-site at the brain and cognitive
sciences building at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology in Cambridge
Massachusetts we are now going to be
talking about programmatically generated
everything we have Daniel Vaghela
joining us on the show hello Helen very
serious yeah Dan's awesome we had him on
already on the show you can check out
the link in the bio to our first episode
together and now we're gonna be
unpacking so much more about what we
missed in that first episode that was
super short only less than 30 minutes
but now we're gonna jump into a deeper
for those that don't know Dan's
background he's the founder and CEO of
emerge the only market research and
company discovery platform focused
exclusively on artificial intelligence
and machine learning he regularly speaks
for audiences of business and government
leaders with the focus on the critical
near-term implication implications of
artificial intelligence across major
sectors including presentations for the
World Bank the UN Interpol and global
pharmaceutical and baking companies and
you can check out the links below to
emerge dan for Joe's website as well as
Twitter and LinkedIn all right let's
start things off with our one of our
favorite questions we find ourselves as
stewards of Earth what is your current
take on the state of our world biased
biased takes from everybody I guess
right given what their their focus and
their background is yeah right now my
take on the state of the world is is a
an increasingly enfeebled and infighting
West
vying for some semblance of
technological relevance in the next 20
years
that that's maybe like a quick synopsis
and and and due to Asia yeah China China
super particularly and for good reason
and sort of what that looks like in
terms of collaboration and clash and
whatever else in in the years ahead so
technological dominance of the
technologies that are going to
absolutely transform the human
experience I think that kind of control
there's going to be a big deal and I
think that that's what the next you know
2030 are gonna be so that's my my hot
take and this is how we ended up in
trowing the episode with Dan there was
such a profound clip where he talked
about the AI substrate monopoly and I
had to put that at the front of the
video to real people in because it was
such a solid way of phrasing and we're
gonna end up talking about that as we go
in I totally agree there's something
interesting going on with the
geopolitical kind of collaboration /
competition between the United States
and China I hope we can just figure out
how to spiritually enrich ourselves to
that oneness and oh yeah yeah dude a
hundred percent I mean who knows how
it'll rattle out but I think that that
is the grand cosmopolitan hope and I'm
with you on that
so yes all right so let's talk about you
know you write so much and in your
writings you're doing a lot of you know
you do a lot of short term implications
with emerge and this is the three
sectors pharmaceutical banking and
defense and cover a lot of Defense and
in the long term you do a lot of writing
do you do a lot of extrapolating of
current trends in terms of especially
yes virtual realities artificial general
intelligence is substrate monopolies etc
and human behavior in psychology so give
us a you know give us a synopsis on your
long term understanding of kind of where
things are headed yeah I mean lots to
potentially unpack I suppose I'm only
one person I guess the best that I can
hope to sort of like maybe pry some
potentialities and in like
specific area but I think a lot about
how the human condition is is changing
and how technologies are enabling sort
of what we're gonna be I think that the
two big questions for Humanity are what
is the trajectory of intelligence and
sentience in other words like what's the
point
and also like how do we get there
without killing each other or just just
all dying violently I think that there
should be UN sustainable development
goals for can humanity get on the same
page about what's after people and can
we figure out a way to have an on arms
race global dynamic to get there so
these are the things I care the most
about
I think that a big part of that shift is
AI enabling economic prominence and and
military sway and power and influence in
a great many ways and I think China has
some tremendous advantages in terms of
how they can wield that compared to the
United States
I'm just the their culture and a whole
bunch of other factors and that
essentially ownership of these virtual
worlds we're going to be creating these
these sort of digital environments that
we're entering is going to be kind of
the other big aspect so it's going to be
the economic military prominence which i
think is going to be swelled by tech and
then I think there's going to be what
happens to people and and I think we go
in I think is the answer you know slowly
initially but but we go in we can go
wherever you want to go from there but
this is kind of big stuff yes that's
beautiful now on the thing that you said
there that really catches and I hope it
sticks with a lot of people is that we
desperately need to be on the same page
globally about a human narrative a human
narrative around what are what's it for
oh so that we can be happy so that we
can be prosperous like super good goals
like prosperity and peace are freaking
awesome goals but but ultimately though
but ultimately though but but for real
though like what will you do from there
you know that's a real question and and
it's not obvious what the answer is I
have seen more efforts at potentially
positive like like utopic brainstorming
and fiction as opposed to dystopic which
I commend as an exercise that it gets
very challenging but I can
it but yeah I really hope we can get on
the same page because what do we we're
gonna we're gonna think that evolution
cuts off from here forever
like why surely the hominids are the end
of all things
well not surely yet to actually get this
to stick and to get it to become a a
United Nations discourse point of
posthuman yeah that's what I'm working
towards man I love that one that one's
critical and it seems like it is should
be on the sustainable development goals
I'm literally I am like the hustle is to
get there right yeah through whatever
means the UN is one of many mediums I
think they're a good one though I have a
lot of respectfully you owe Davos is
another one
yeah well Lincoln on the forum for sure
you know I mean you know the World Bank
could potentially be a conduit I mean
there's there's a bunch but uh but yet
to have some global discourse around
like but really people what what are we
gonna do really then you already see it
happening in every single aspect of of
wealth being concentrated and artificial
intelligence working on behalf of
certain yeah yeah that discourse is
massively farther along there was 18
months ago yeah yeah yeah which is
awesome which is awesome yeah yeah
because then we're actually solving
those yeah we're trying to get to the
we're trying to get to the near-term
stuff right and that's where we pay our
bills is you know a bank will want to
you know do AI with stuff where or the
you know the World Bank will would be
able to get interested in the economic
implications of something but but yeah
be cool to get it a little farther yes
so now as we talked about this is how
this is a hard thing sometimes for true
people to wrap their minds around when
for those that have already seen what
has happened with the 40 last around 40
years of going from pong to the photo
video realistic three-dimensional RPG
games that we play being able to strap
yourself into those game
is kind of what we're talking about with
these virtually designed worlds and then
one's ability to not only play in Dan's
design world but also to create one's
own world that has nothing to do with
our universe completely different laws
yeah bro we can take this from so many
angles but um there's there's a bunch
here I think that ultimately people
don't want anything that people say they
want people want the fulfillment of
their drives or the
Aristotle you know all things are done
for happiness analogy is relevant but of
course happiness boils down to whatever
fulfillment of whatever Drive so you
know do we really want relationships do
we really want sleep do we really want
food or do we want different kinds of
fulfill of perceived fulfillment we'll
gain from certain kinds of experience
really we want varieties of experience
that feel like achievement we want
varieties of experience that feel like
joy we want varieties that we want
changes in qualia and sense and when
when that stuff is is push-button when
that stuff's on-demand there is no
bigger market for anything outside of
perception because because that's the
market for reality because because that
that's reality so so the market for
perception is the market
it's the ultimate market and as we get
into eventually neuro tech and BMI which
which I've been rel that was my
introduction into the into all of this
AI world as through there but even just
just VR and the future steps there I
mean that's in my opinion where we're
headed and I think that there's Japan is
kind of the canary in the coalmine of
sort of what happens with the first
world you get rich there's no meaning
because there isn't and then you get sad
and you escaped into virtual worlds and
I think that that's that's what the
whole rich first world is going to do
you know a lot of the males anyway and
that ultimately that's that's attention
that we'll have to somehow resolve or
maybe turn into something constructive
but yeah lots lots of poke into there
okay off of that the qualia catalog I
love that point that was so interesting
so our ability to just browse through
whatever experiences
people don't want sleep they don't want
girlfriends they don't want food they
don't want anything and so when you can
give them that thing that's that's the
end of it we don't want physical bodies
we don't want to have to cut our nails
we don't want to have to like I don't
know we don't want to have to have
relationships to feel happy right we
don't want to like maybe we do right
maybe maybe we want relationships we
don't want to need them we don't want to
hurt if we don't have them in the same
ways we don't want any of the things we
all sensibly one we want variety in
qualia and any technologies that start
to vehemently and robustly fulfill that
pharmacologically brain machine
interface VR that's the market the
market ends with that um and that is
also the way that that people will
extend their abilities and power because
that's that will be cognitive
enhancements that will permit them to
control more of these technologies an
unenhanced person you know maybe 30 40
years from now will have essentially no
chance of really running the show but
yet that's the deal the quality of
catalog that's your term not mine
no there's no there's no there's someone
else
Alex K Chen was like Alan said neural
real-estate that's his term and I'm just
like dude none of these are any ones all
right they're just coming through
special respectful brain there were just
being we're vehicles we are vehicles for
the for the ideas and for the
selflessness and the and the projects to
be channeled through into the 3d world
Emersonian of you we taking that on in
that sort of an essence it transcends
our ego it gets us way past any of the I
love it okay so quality catalog it's the
push-button ability to be able to peruse
any experience and experiences that you
want and and yeah that does cuz they can
jump right to love you can jump right to
Machu Picchu you can jump right to the
bottom of the ocean that's how it starts
but it's not how it ends so it starts
with fulfillments that we think we want
because we're idiots because because we
only know what monkeys know we only have
the range of qualia that monkeys have
and so if we imagine let's say like like
crickets like fulfilling qualia for
crickets like we'll just make the
analogy real quick is it yes Machu
Picchu sex like
I really want to like I want to I want
to I want to smack that like through
that glass roof real quick okay so let's
go down first to just quickly down into
what it's like to be an eagle right and
actually have the quality experience of
flying through the sky or the big
dolphins or whales right or octopus
right there's so many other animals or
insects to explore and then yes there's
so many senses that we don't have that
maybe other species do you know chemical
senses of ants or what have you or you
know dolphins echolocation or I mean you
know it's scratching the surface with
these ideas you know the the dexterity
and proprioception of you know lemurs
right we don't we can't we can't do some
of the stuff they can do but but so this
is a range and we have some positions
around which of these experience we want
so if we're to select in the catalogue I
forget what was it was it was it a car
was it lock was it now I'm dropping it
but if you only know the concepts of
gold and the concept of a duck you can't
imagine anything except for a golden
duck or gold and a duck like you can
only combine the ideas you have so our
quality quality a catalog is only going
to be of the things that we think we
want um but but ultimately it will
there's a slippery slope into other
realms other other domains so we'll
we'll want Machu Picchu we'll want love
but if if we're not hindered by our
current hardware there will be
permutations of positive experience to
which we are now not now privy just like
monkeys are not pretty to enjoy let's
say you know reading Montaigne or or
reading Francis Bacon or something like
they just don't get that much out of it
or they they can't watch like a good
stand-up routine and like dig it or oil
painting for example there are entire
realms of those things to which we have
zero access and presuming we can start
to creek out at the corners I think that
there will be people who spend most of
their time kind of physical body as husk
spend most of their time even if they
are working with inhuman Hardware
experiencing things through senses and
through limbs and threw like
permutations of light and whatnot that
humans would never experience in the
world of atoms like it just turns into
whatever mill you boo
your your aims and for most people
that's just the fulfillment of desires
so yeah the the market begins with
selling people on jacuzzis with Mariah
Carey like 1998 you know what I mean
like that's that's how you sell it you
sell it like that but but but that's not
where it ends
yes yes okay so there's both there's
both the the designing of what is in the
quality library or catalog so our
ability to go and design it ourselves
and then there's our ability to go and
immerse into what other people are
designing I'm really curious as to how
this would actually work getting us into
the are these 3d bodies meat puppets
into that qualia cataloging ability how
do we how do we get us into yeah its
phasic so I well I suspect it'll be
Facebook right like I'm speaking like
I'm prognosticating and doing anything
other than prognosticating I the the
meat puppet
I like the monkey suit I use the monkey
suit on the rig yeah just a tracksuit
just talking the monkey suit so yeah I I
think this will first get there through
through VR much more robust VR than we
have now
but I think that VR for gaming is that
is a really limited use case I think
that when VR becomes normal is III have
predicted and we'll see if this is the
case could be horrendously wrong here
that when VR becomes productive in other
words when you essentially sort of have
to use it to do certain kinds of jobs or
you know like so I have like three
monitors up at home when I can have like
a screen here and I can have as many
monitors as I want running as many
programs as I want at whatever font size
and whatever volume as I want in a much
more you know with with less plastic and
glass being used unless energy being
used in the future right that's very
hard to computationally to bring all of
that into this small lens but eventually
it won't be won't be horribly
challenging that once you kind of can't
not use it just like cell phones it's
like it was sort of novel the cool kids
were texting but then it's like well you
need to get food don't you you know you
need to like check your email don't you
you need to make
that sales call don't you and then at
some point everybody has to when that
social pressure from the the pragmatic
perspective comes into VR I suspect
that's when the going in will sort of
begin so it would be like a phase one of
sorts yeah so this is like phase two of
going in from the cell phone smartphone
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe it
is a phase two lord knows what phase it
is but yeah but III suspect that you
know we're a we're on that we're riding
the we're riding the the toboggan here
of of going in you also made it clear
that it is that again it's that you
become less productive if you choose to
not use it yeah and you get access to
less experiences less productivity it's
a yes so you or societal the cultural
push is to use it yes you can't you
can't not I mean technology is a
language right if you really want to
like you know you can't not speak yeah
like how are you gonna think and so you
know these will be this is this is
extended cognition right there's
distributed cognition and this is this
is kind of where these things in many
respects are headed I suspect that
gaming will be a reasonably isolated use
case and that when the pragmatic pull
occurs and you kind of can't not or it
to leverage the double negative there on
the that's sort of like the when the
toboggan ride starts really kind of heat
up a little bit really speed up um but
but that's that's just VR that's just
you know you know like like eyeglasses
type stuff from there VR will get to the
point where VR is not um analog may or
may not be the right term but I'm gonna
use it analog meaning like you're
receiving it and and someone else is
giving it like okay IVR and I can see my
screens or VR and I can like see a movie
or I can browse through book really fast
have all the good stuff kind of brought
to me um eventually these VR
environments will be designed to be
who've our own aims whether our aims are
I'm anxious and I don't want to be
anxious and you can enter some kind of a
VR space maybe have some kind of EEG of
some sort and and go through whatever
experience you require in order to kind
of calm down or maybe get excited or
whatever the the case may be or maybe
learn something in the future I would
hope that
I could say in VR you know just put it
on and be like I'd like to learn about
the French Revolution through the
perspective of st. juste in 45 minutes
and and just have a programmatically
generated biography of the man who by
all accounts should have been more
prominent than Bonaparte had he not had
his head cut off um just just get it
taken a guy it's so hard to cobble
together all those perspectives but
they're all out there and a computer
system could hypothetically put them
together it's been movies of the man and
so we at least have some actors that
could kind of play them out and so when
we can call upon whatever we want to
call upon whether we ask that of our
email like oh well for all the sales you
know for all the accounts that are that
haven't raised even 10 million yet like
we're gonna send some permutation of
this but but fill it out with whatever
the last press release was in yadda
yadda when when what we command and what
we receive are both tailored and
customized based on our own aims
that'll be sort of leaning into you know
what I'm kind of calling a phase 2 so
this is the programmatically generated
everything world right where you can say
geez it would be neat to you know be in
a jacuzzi with Marat you know is that
you're the write on the on the
especially on the learning side of
things to to be able to just call forth
a five-minute video lesson of some topic
another one is just a we were using the
the meat sticks on the device file it's
so paired with all the 40 board is like
the it's like the chisel it's like it's
just it's just it's like it's like
caveman noises its offensive it's as
good as we go this is pastas possible
when I think the message get the message
done just like that yeah well yeah okay
so but that's phasing into the next and
then this is this this eventually I
would suspect will will lean towards
advanced haptic experiences to go along
with this kind of VR nai at some point
at some point I suspect that between
haptics stuff between VR and like AI
enhanced vr the programmatically
generated everything idea the deep fakes
but on steroids and in all directions
again like I said with Rose Pierre but
with anything else and then how I think
the glasses one or slash optics right
there's so many ways to explore that one
in the computational capacity also being
able to be outsourced to the cloud so
that way you can remain right so there's
that getting there getting there and
then but the one that I also want to
hear your thoughts on to help people
with the with the capacity to visualize
it how do we get into this full scale
haptic suit that helps us with that yeah
yeah I I I think I think that
increasingly again as work permits us to
wear this as we can garner some maybe
admittedly in the beginning meddling but
but at some point non middling
experience of relationships in this like
our ability to to relate to connect
eventually there will be
programmatically generated friends that
are just better than your friends are
I'm not even knocking my friends like I
love my it's like one of like the few
like the rare like like like this monkey
suit thing isn't it like as horrible as
like it imagine if your friends were
constantly in there like peak state of
stimulating yeah yeah but but but like a
bajillion of all join like imagine if
you could be like oh like I want someone
with all the insights of [ __ ] Pericles
and you know you know Einstein and
whatever and and to have no none of
their own personal goals and only want
to coach me on what this is a particular
objective is right give me a break I
mean it's just really hard to compete
with that now it's gonna be hard to get
there but man programmatically generated
anything three years ago compared to now
is like insane it's just insane progress
and now whether we can do that with
personalities I think it's gonna be a
challenge but I suspect it'll happen I
think that as we start to fulfill more
and more things to those means people
are going to sort of be in yeah I
predict eventually there will be some
kind of reclined environments designed
to go into this mode right we're not
gonna we're not gonna be sitting up in
office chairs wearing these things we're
gonna have somewhere where we can
comfortably write our back isn't going
to hurt
just be in the real world which is the
world of perception because it's the
only real world bang right there now at
some point haptics are gonna fit into
whatever that thing okay so okay so it
says so it's it's a way we are
potentially going to be laying flat so
that we're comfortable potentially even
in some sort of a like a float tank or a
zero gravity chamber or something I
think I think at some point I mean it
might it might be at the level where BMI
starts to come in where we're like we're
not only laying back but you got the
matrix plug action going on um it may be
before or after that but I predict many
people live in a husk like condition
whereby even the excretion of waste will
occur in this environment and there will
be some set up it's a prediction
there'll be some degree of a setup where
we just don't want to leave and leave
when when we need to that there would be
some way it just it just this is all
pushing me towards thinking that we are
already in that environment yeah yeah
we're we're already in that exact thing
that you're describing that when you
when you say were in the design world
levelling up you know we're building our
experience points and our catalog of
qualia that's how is that not already
what's happening right now nobody nobody
wants to go to the bathroom nobody who
wants to sleep what do you want you want
the fulfillment of your drives which is
whatever quality you want in front of
you and that quality may involve
learning things creating things
achieving things or it just may involve
bliss in all directions either way it
doesn't involve trimming your damned
fingernails it doesn't involve going to
the bathroom it doesn't involve I don't
know maybe it doesn't involve physical
friends at some point like I'm not an
anti human anti friend guy that's not
what I'm saying like like but a
programmatically general at some point
like it is what it is right you're not
you're not bad for you know thinking
language is useful or the wheel is
useful or you know the typewriter was
useful or whatever else you you're not
bad to suspect that some of these things
will be useful and fulfilling in their
own way as well people will get to pick
exactly what they want to browse versus
in the physical world you can't and
that's your
Adams versus [ __ ] thing Adams are just
so so lame and and I mean like you can
use them to build these other worlds but
like wow they're just they're just so
cold and uncaring and not that like bits
are caring but but it's just at least
there's some like we've done pretty well
designing the world of atoms we've done
pretty well you know me and you we got
running water whenever we want it get
these funky devices and whatnot like
really masterful use of atoms but but
bits will just permit so much more of
what we want and potentially less of
what we don't want there's obviously new
insidious forces that will enter the
world of bits that aren't possible in
the world of atoms but but I predict
that that the the blossoming of the
possible in the beneficial sense will be
far too good to ignore ok so then with
that phases were we're thinking that the
virtual worlds give extremely good and
the computational capacity here then the
haptics come in then the state of the
brain computer interfaces as a brain
machine interfaces so then were I want
if I'm really interested to know how
that technology is actually going to be
able to work exactly how do you take
that what's happening up here with our
experience and connected to a computer
and then be able to enhance it and then
that kind of opens us up to all these
other worlds yeah well do you want to go
into sort of that I think the end game
of all of that by the way is eventually
like the body already is a husk there's
just someone I forget what biography was
of Emerson but someone had described
Emerson is that his body was only the
office of his mind in other words it was
just like a physical space to house you
know the real stuff the thinking and I
think already that's sort of where were
where we're headed and eventually that
that would should it be possible lead to
the upload scenario you know how do you
think we're gonna how do you think we're
gonna have an interface how does the
mind get interface with the computer do
we have like a technical understanding
of how that will work
I I I am
far from the man for that job although I
will say since 2013 when I first started
interviewing the people at brain gates
at Brown University who did the early
work on controlling a robotic arm to
grab food and eat it and whatnot for
folks who are paraplegic and a lot of
that work is fascinating the limitations
are super evident you know and and the
the the the necessity to retrain these
models to sort of understand the
circuitry and the response of the brain
to some kind of you know invasive
substrate in the mind like the the
synapses around it sort of not
responding the same way as they used to
and needing to kind of like rejigger
things to some degree and seeing how
kind of oblong and haphazard it is um
it's really clear that we have a ways to
go I don't think any of this is is maybe
it you know a decade off I think we're
gonna be I think I think it'll become
more and more evident that we're going
in and I think it'll become more and
more evident that whoever owns a
substrate is is is is the man and the
colloquial sense of like the bad big guy
um okay so we're gonna let the creative
powers of however the brain computer
interfaces end up working it's gonna
it's likely we're moving that direction
and it's just we're pretty certain this
can happen and there's going to be some
creative permutations of how it ends up
successfully entering into the world but
this is kind of the general hopefully
50-ish yeah yeah I I would I would say
you know I would say within like if we
don't have some semblance of potentially
available BMI within 25 or 30 years I'll
be somewhat surprised like consumer
accessible may be wealthy within within
25 or 30 I'll actually be surprised
given the trajectory of things but yeah
yeah it'd be super cool to have folks
from neural link and brain gate and
whatever else I mean just the fact that
we have four years of interviewing these
people everyone was focused exclusively
on the ameliorative applications that is
to say people with strokes people with
Parkinson's etc right that's where all
of the money was going and even when I
would poke and prod him off the mic
but really though I mean what could this
stuff do cold like that was not the
focus overtly not the focus and now you
have Colonel you have neural link and
there will be others and I think you
know if we keep kind of cracking away
we'll get somewhere but yeah the exact
house on that I think are rightfully
challenging and another one of the
things is that it gives us control right
we were talking about being able to
browse through the catalog and find
whatever experiences we want people want
to be in full control so if you do want
to clip nails go for it if you don't
happy birthday buddy yeah good for you
yeah and then another the other one that
I think you mentioned is really good
it's just that you you do get this kind
of like this one directional love from
friends or family or and it's just much
different than needing to give love in
the other direction as well and the kind
of the reciprocal altruism I'm not
saying this is conjuring of virtue right
I'm just saying it's fulfilling drives
and I'm just saying that that's what
people are doing is fulfilling drives
that's been your phrase that you've been
using over and over again so the quality
catalog is about me being able to
fulfill whatever drive whenever I want
yeah and I think the only chance that we
would have at greater degrees of
volition should we have any to start
with would be extending sort of the base
brain that we have which is based on all
of these drives I think if we want
freedom we don't want freedom with with
the lizard brain at the bottom we want
freedom in a more overt sense I'm not
saying that's easy but I it's very clear
to me that freedom or control within the
limited hardware and software that we
have is is kind of a kind of a paltry
idea ok so then once we do get to this
hopefully let's say commercialize state
of being able to tap into
super super intelligence and let's say
550 years something around those lines
so then that really gives us the ability
to kind of like with a joystick in a
program to just be able to think what we
want to generate and then to be able to
jump into those experiences and that's
kind of where we're at with this
programmatically generated everything
and then it's sort of like who owns it
okay so now here's the next question why
don't you give us your thoughts on the
who owns it yeah yeah so the the
substrate monopoly hypothesis here this
my general idea is that in the next for
the remainder of this century the the
grand conflicts be they between great
powers right like Luxembourg and like a
200-person company and like I don't know
Taiwan or something like our out of this
picture the great powers so in the
commercial side that would be your
Google's and your Baidu's and and
whatnot on the nation side that it's
pretty much just the US and China maybe
at some point in deal come into the game
maybe at some point the US will fade off
but keep being idiots but great power
conflict come militarily economically
and technologically in the next for the
remainder of the century is ultimately
about controlling the substrate that
houses the powerful AI and houses the
majority of human experience because
moat you know most the first world is
going to be in some permutation of this
it might not look like that right maybe
there still will be screens but the
virtual world will be where things
really happen it will be real it will be
very very real it will be where the
majority of important things happen
business or otherwise so the controlling
of the totality of human experience
owning the virtual ecosystems that are
programmatically creating you know what
what most of humanity is experiencing
that is controlling reality like in the
most direct sense controlling other
people's perception is controlling
reality so that the ultimate end game
should you want the top of the dominance
hierarchy on earth would be to control
the substrate that houses all of that
stuff and so if a company is is going to
aim to you know win
that kind of grand sense then that's how
you do it if a country would want to
then that's how they would do it China
is certainly farther along that road at
least culturally than the United States
is in terms of you know the ability to
kind of put people into an ecosystem
that's managed but yeah that's the
that's hypothesis hypothesis whoever
loads you in and whoever kind of manages
whatever is programmatically generating
your experience is the deity okay and I
want to continue going into substrate
monopoly in a moment because at the same
time there's this really important
principle to layer in here which is that
it's as though there's a difference
between the rori into the the qualia
catalog with the intention to just go
into whatever blissful states possible
and forget the real world yeah and then
the ones that go into qualia catalog and
explore and experience meanwhile pull it
back and look at oh is it Google or
Baidu is it China or the United States
so it's so still keeping at least a
finger on the you call this the Lotus
Eaters versus the world leaders yeah
yeah so there I think that there's gonna
be this dynamic where I think most
people and rightfully so if we look at
the great religions you know which which
I don't necessarily use as like super
important reference points like oh why
why it was written a long time ago you
know so it must be but but I think that
there's something to it that that these
stories have have persisted and have had
credence there's there's you know sort
of breaking the veil in Christianity you
know this this sort of a love tiers
where the world is suffering but there's
sort of this world beyond it such a
similar notion in you know Buddhism and
in Hindu traditions and whatnot this
idea of kind of last breaking beyond
what we know as the state of nature the
state of anxiety the state of drives
that have have perpetuated meat from
doing meat stuff and and on some degree
anything with living parts even with
cell walls from doing living part stuff
so the the escaping of that world of the
state of nature to some degree is sort
of like the great promise and hope right
the heavens so to speak and so being
able to bring that down
to earth is I think what most people are
after um I think I think that's why
people do the majority of what they do
but at the same time I suspect that
there are are some people who would be
of the belief that if you are entering a
world like that and someone else
ultimately has built the technology
that's generating whatever you want to
you know generate and someone else is
controlling the substrate the physical
substrate where your experiences are all
housed and from whence your all of your
experience come from that that at the
very end of the day that person is safer
than you and I think that that is a a
right supposition now I'm not here to
argue that everybody should try to get
to the top of that pyramid I hope that
there's some way to square that circle
and we can blossom to whatever is
posthuman when it makes sense how it
makes sense um in a way that makes sense
but but I do suspect that many people
will will not be okay with eating the
lotus with we simply experiencing
creativity or having the feelings of
kind of exploration whatnot they'll want
to use cognitive enhancement and VR and
these other substrates to extend their
ability to potentially wield control and
ultimately to control the substrate or
to at least persist have some kind of a
more tangible impact rather than a
qualia tornado in their own isolated
little computational sugar cube that
that that will will nyog xizt after they
are gone they're you know this is a
supposition yeah because their desire to
want to be a part of the bigger picture
outside of the sugar cube is such a
again interesting drive that we for some
people for some people and we could
potentially decide to not want that
drive but it just in just in general how
to actually make it so that is it is it
does it end up becoming a hierarchy with
with a monopolistic substrate that has a
bunch of sugar cubes in it and some of
them are able to reflect back and say
hey we still know that you're in control
why are you more safe and more powerful
than we are and how do we figure out how
do if we start the conversations with
the United Nations this full circle
with the companies with these think-tank
approach how do we jump into the
substrate in a way that is potentially
owned and decisions made by oh by by by
all this would be the dream right this
would be the dream I I think that that
would be the dream I think that there
there would need to be some kind of a
genuine cosmopolitan spirit to get that
done again I think the two big questions
are what's after people and how do we
get there without you know all dying
violently and I think that some degree
of global governance and same page
admitting the default state for the
development of all these technologies is
kind of an arms race dynamic rightfully
so state of nature I'm not saying I like
it
nothing I'm perpetuating it I'm not
saying I I I love nothing more than
autonomous weapons but I'm saying that
that's how it works
sort of unless we can come to some other
agreement and even then it's
trepidatious you know the what's the
what's the saying that the the kingdom
long United will at some point divide
the kingdom long divided right so it we
can only we could only hold that
together for so long but hopefully we
could have that tentative peace for long
enough to bump ourselves into blissful
Quaglia land for as long as we got but
uh that's the tough part it seems as
though the spiritual enlightenment of us
to a degree of self-actualization and
transcendence an understanding of the
unity and oneness that if we can get
this to children at young enough ages
that we could potentially more slow down
and think our way to the substrates then
the and simultaneously compete for the
best ideas but in a way that doesn't get
us to arms races where people have to
unnecessarily suffer I I think I'm gonna
push on that idea a little bit in my
most optimistic I'm completely with you
and I will say this much as much as I
rail and lament against the particular
vices and luxuries of and entitled
feebleness of the millennial serve world
of which I'm part the softness I think
that the cosmopolitan inclination is
very natural
for for Millennials and I think that as
Millennials come to run things they
might need like avocado toast and like
like other lame millennial type stuff
but but I think that they will be real
cool cross culture compared to let's say
their grandparents sure who might in
some cases still have some sway in some
parts and then what will their kids and
grandkids look like in terms of their
ethics being really evolved a hundred
percent maybe they will demand that
world peace
aye aye aye in an optimistic world I'm
with you in a non optimistic
you know if I'm real cold with myself I
wonder if evolved is necessarily the
right word I think it certainly is kind
it certainly is friendly you and I
certainly look virtuous by touting it
but to suspect that in some ultimate
sense it is higher I think is sort of
presume that we understand what's going
on when in fact whenever so if we go
from you know the monkeys can't
understand Shakespeare and then you have
3% genetic difference humans when we do
that next 3% genetic difference any
ideas you and I have about ethics are
gobbledygook that would be sort of their
their highest level would be
gobbledygook because there will be
grander modes and demeans of valuing
grander modes and means of understanding
morality when whenever we access that
higher degree of intelligence so I want
to think that like it's all unity man
you know I want to get like real Eastern
and like the cool sense and it certainly
appears mega virtuous but but I I
actually wonder whether that's evolved
or not dangerous thoughts but I'm just
trying to be frank with myself yeah I
have similar feelings to you in that
front that there's no sort of way to
just assure oneself that it is one or
the other but it does it's a really good
point and I really love the idea of
trying to get there
but the so do I yeah I know I know I
know I know
I'm dragging you into like a sad place
Alan I didn't mean to do that let's go
into something that you'll enjoy well
yeah you're you bring up you bring up
very good points though and and we'll
see how the ethics of nature want us all
to unite and be friendly or this nature
want us to just rip each other's heads
off um you know like when I look out
into nature like I actually don't know
evolutions not done 100% so that's
that's one of the questions is that you
look back and you see yeah there's a lot
of evolution that had that had war in it
and violence at the same time you look
at some of the evolution and there
wasn't that and you also look at what
could happen moving forward and is it
potentially that a civilization that in
that figures out how to be at complete
peace and transcendent harmony with one
another and their substrates that they
dive into that the ones that figure out
how to do that in the most kind way
possible loving way possible those are
the ones that become pinnacle
civilizations the ideal example of a
civilization on Iraq and the moon shall
inherit the earth said Alan
well you know we'll see we'll see I have
my fingers crossed that the cosmopolitan
spirit will continue to breathe its life
into you know minds and that we'll be
able to get on some degree of same page
adness around what else monkeys want to
do in the big game
yeah but the competition doesn't move it
along and it gets the good it gets good
ideas remember slowing down and thinking
is also very important along the way how
do we transition from this these
substrate monopolies that are happening
would you call the substrate monopoly
super intelligences um could be I I
think that you know in the in the
reclined scenario which I doubt would be
all the way back although like there's
some organ aaahm except sport that would
probably understand that game I'm far
from that even at that level I think so
right now Facebook and Google quite
obviously wield vastly more power than
than a great number of nations in terms
of just global influence of culture
probably more than on money or a hundred
and fifty even other nations yeah a
hundred percent and they're super aware
of that like I was speaking with a woman
who's very high up at the United Nations
just crashed at her house and like got
to talking about like the real stuff you
know what I mean like the this stuff we
couldn't talk about it in a in you know
on the mic with the translators and
she'd mentioned being at the World
Economic Forum and talking to one of the
Google guys and just sort of addressing
very frankly like the the potential are
asking very frankly do you believe that
your company is more powerful than the
nation's and just sort of seeing like
the most knowing possible smile and nod
but then like a kind of different
trajectory for the conversation but like
a full-blown acknowledgement of it right
because these are the folks that are in
the virtual worlds that we live in
I'm not even calling them bad right I
think it's normal to say the powerful
are bad and the weak are good I think
everybody is self-interested the story
ends there
so a moral selfish egoic animals not
necessarily a moral is different than a
moral right a morals just void
morality and and I think that writ large
those people know that that's where
they're there Zuckerberg bought oculus I
think thinking VR was gonna take off
faster but think about it my good man
when your relations to your co-workers
and to your family and to I don't know
even the people upstairs they're just
better and more immersive here suck
owning that space is the big game man
that's that's getting to the right we
talked about what the top is that's
getting to the top that's getting to the
real place and I'm not saying another
thing it's good to get there I'm not
saying everyone should be vying for it
but it would make sense and so yeah I
mean there's companies that are there
already
I think there's firms that are already
there and are gonna want to kind of
continue that momentum forward and some
of them are pursuing the virtual reality
augmented reality hololens to route
right the microsoft as well so some of
them are pursuing that route meanwhile
the kernel and neural links are going
directly for the brain which is also
very interesting so there's kind of like
which one of those two will yeah there's
a competing ecosystem of extending
intelligence yeah yeah yeah and so if we
do call those things kind of little in a
sense they are their own substrates that
are maybe they're they're kind of pre
super intelligence maybe yeah I think
they might be managed by people
initially when we're just in the
recliners it might still be people at
the top like kazakian Page and whoever
else and not not bad people I'm not
calling suck a bad person I'm just
saying it might be people at the top in
China it'll be very clearly the people
at the top in China it will have to be a
party thing so it may just be people but
I think eventually it will have to be
cognitively enhanced people if that
becomes viable at all and eventually
whatever manages the substrate so long
as we don't blow ourselves up will be
something posthuman whatever you know
whatever it would big spidery legs
matrix style manages all the compute
will be something drastically beyond
beyond people but I think it might start
just like an evolution of what it is an
out so it doesn't have to be super
intelligence I think long enough game if
we don't all die and blow ourselves up
that would be what it would get to yes
okay and then I want to know about the
kind of
you know we talked about this a little
bit but the super intelligence itself
the substrates themselves this replaces
the top that are the humans up to even
at the top and their positions replaces
them as well and then how do we ensure
that the the super intelligence that the
transhumanist transition that this
process that it happens in in a way that
we've made that maximizes our potential
to even continue being around and I'll
give you a frank addressing of your
question and then I'll question your
question the Frank addressing of your
question I think the best possible
scenario for us in terms of the trans
human transition the best possible
scenario for us as selfish individual
consciousnesses would be to through
uploading or whatever other means may
never be possible some degree of BMI
exists
borderline perpetually in whatever
permutations of blissful ultimate
created deity experience we as an
individual consciousness want that would
be as high an endgame as we could hope
for the very idea that cognitively
enhanced people will like get together
and like like agree on things and sort
of get along on earth I think is
completely and viable because if we
think about um things that think
differently things that are let's say
50% smarter than baseline hominids just
the idea that the same degree of human
peace and prosperity that we share now
tentative as it is would in any way
persist is is is lame we're gonna have
to do all this our expansion to vastly
greater degrees of creativity and
capability is gonna have to happen in
virtual worlds cuz if have since in the
physical world we're killing each other
I'm just just calling the shots on that
one I'm gonna throw it out there so it's
gonna have to happen virtually and the
best case scenario a long term is we're
just digitized the uploading and then
eventually digest it at some point
whatever manages that substrate will
have better stuff to do with the compute
that we are or like a Sun will expand
and like eat us or something but the
best we have is digitized and digested
and as many hyper sped-up years as many
hyper sped of billions of years of mega
expansive quality of our individual
consciousness is as good as it gets and
then were digested that says that's as
good as it gets that I think would be
the pivotal endgame of the trans human
transition should we should we aim to
maintain some semblance of the seed of
our own unique sentient bubble that we
sort of live in there is a question
though as to whether the goal of the
trans human transition is the happiness
of the monkeys now now this is bad
people ideas right I'm sure what I
should do Alan I mean that's being
recorded so what I should do is say that
why certainly the happiness of hominids
is ultimately the the moral outcome that
all of us should shoot for for eternity
and of course billions and billions of
years from now and there's vastly more
intelligent things than people the most
pre-eminently important consideration of
all future intelligence will be the
happiness of the monkeys this this would
be a position of virtue this would
signal to you of course that I'm a good
person but I'm actually not sure about
that sort of long ball just long ball
right like whatever
chimps thought was the highest thing
whatever crickets thought was the
highest thing just wasn't the highest
thing when there was something to think
of higher things and so at the end of
the day is it if it is utilitarian stuff
right let's pretend that the end game
right the machine wakes up and says I've
conceived of with with you know a
planet-sized compute I've conceived of
all ways of morally measuring the good
and as it turns out utilitarianism is
right ye little hominids ye jeremy
bentham's of the world why why how smart
you were you little chimps but but you
hit on it and you know what now I'm
going to maximise it the maximization of
utility does in no way has to do with
hominid well-being right you could
hypothetically build positive qualia in
a much more efficient sense without
having to maintain if optimizing utility
is the goal my unique conscious string
my memories of playing Nintendo 64 as a
child you know what I mean and like
eating string cheese and stuff that's
wasted compute there's a way to just
shake more pure bliss out of just like
computron 'i'm then there is by housing
individual sentences
so if utilitarianism is the goal monkey
happiness may or may not be my my
supposition is that it's something
vastly beyond utilitarianism that you
can't think of and I can't think of yeah
yeah and with the merge scenario there
is potentially the embeddedness of our
existence within the super intelligence
so that we can kind of be in the
playground of it to come up with these
and feel the creativity of this may be
there is a unity element there right
yeah there's a way to become part of the
great right and there's all these
religious analogies to that but you
might be onto something yeah that could
be nicely the complete merging of the
humans with the super intelligence that
could be quite nice yeah and that could
give us quality a catalog eradication of
suffering no substrate monopolies just
the well complete oneness potentially
there could be a good side of this coin
like a really really good side of this
of this coin as well but I also do see a
lot of way you were poking at throughout
the convo yeah monkey happiness not sure
I think it's it's it's what we should
shoot for today no doubt about it a
billion years from now I am I am I am
not certain about that
how about we do simulation questions
openers because I know that we didn't
get to get to these last two questions
the first time we sat down together so
are we in a simulation so I I have a
response to this the simulation argument
is jarring if you have ever considered
yourself in base reality in the first
place so if you've thought of yourself
in base reality for a long time then
it's it's a jarring argument um if if
you've been agnostic about like the
floor underneath your feet then like
like who cares and and so it's only
jarring if you've considered yourself to
be in base reality like I have I have
I'm unable to escape Humes Fork right
like there's things that are true in and
of themselves like a triangle has three
sides you know what I mean
and then there's there's
exception of which of which all could be
not right of which all could be the the
Cartesian demon dancing different things
in front of me like if if you're there
then the simulation argument is just not
not a big deal um I would also suspect
it may be the case but I would say it's
a super anthropomorphic analogy as well
in my in my my own supposition like we
use the analogy of video games right I
can imagine if a cricket could imagine
something grand right it would be we
talked about a duck in gold right would
be like a golden duck so what do we have
me and you have computers right we have
we have compute that that builds a
virtual world and and we suspect that in
some ultimate universal sense that that
this is this same right that the gods
have compute and that like maybe maybe
that they type or something the idea
that that sort of our any analogy that
we know any golden duck that we can
conceive of is the actual big game is
like paltry nominal gobbledygook paltry
nominal gobbledygook it's just as likely
to be pink mist
pink mist under the bed of like an ogre
as it is to be like a computer running a
simulation it's like it's it's the exact
same level of likeliness like we're
crickets and we're trying to imagine a
big game like we don't get it the only
answer is access higher intelligence and
try to figure it out you idiot
that is the only answer there is no
other possible answer than that and so
the simulation target for me is that I
don't care so we gain a greater degree
of intelligence potentially even to the
degree of the super intelligence and
then we're able to really understand
what it would be like to compute with
wildest imaginations whatever run these
different permutations of civilizations
orbiting stars or even not civilizations
orbiting stars but things that are out
smily outside there's no physics outside
of atoms on yes and the answer may never
be Alan that we figure out what it is oh
you know what now that we're the size of
a Sun with our compute
you know we're not living in a
simulation we're living in a my guess is
that just goes on forever that there are
always edges of never knowing and that
eventually there's like heat death or
something but we at least explore feebly
on our way there maybe there is some way
out right maybe there's some way out of
this of this ultimately catastrophic
Universal scenario that we're in and but
but of course we would need we would
need a lot of compute to get there and
the last question Dan is where's the
most beautiful thing in the world
maybe ideas
it's kind of an escapist take on like
the world because it's the conception of
something beyond it but I don't know
it's where my mind goes immediately you
know I could say tulips probably a
better better better par for the course
answer but yeah maybe maybe ideas maybe
ideas I don't know I don't know do you
mean this in like a non abstract way
like you want me to talk about like
things that I find beautiful just like
visually in whatever since that's okay
yeah it's probably it from for me my
good man I think that's uh I think
there's always a hope that that that
whatever those are will be beautiful and
yeah that's that's the swing I'll take
that's where I'll stand on that ideas
are the most beautiful thing okay cool
and I also like seeing you in the state
of kind of like surrendering to not
knowing it's nice because you had you
had it throughout the convo you were
just like I feel real firm about that
simulation deal man like I'd love to I'd
love to go hard on somebody who has a
firm stance on that but I just feel like
monkeys talking like that's that's
that's where I'm at with it yeah I hear
you civilization is in fact that the
collaboration of the monkeys building
the world and it's it's what good
monkeys we're valuable monkeys I love my
thinking of intelligence that surpasses
us with the creative potential to
explore what exists beyond this world
and all the potentials creatively it's
just so beautiful and I agree with you
let's okay so yeah you wanted to ask I
had one last question for you yes so
you're asking me about simulations let
me grill you a little bit this is the
simulation what what is the end game of
the simulation like yeah it's a good
question so yeah right now we're
featuring tons of different people at
the edge of their fields at the edge of
knowledge trying to make it really
relatable and inspire other people to
get engaged and inspired it's good to at
least find people that message us from
around the world that are saying things
like I changed my trajectory to care
more about that field that I watched a
video about and so that at least is I
think getting people more interested in
science technology art and just getting
people in education that's not pay wold
and yeah and so that's at least that and
then the end I mean end game right I
don't even know to morrow or the next
day right but there's some things in the
vision like we do love Cambridge and
we'd love to have a recording studio
second one out here on the East Coast
and that's hopefully 2020 and then
hopefully as well helping make you know
community creative warehouse is another
interesting thing that we care about a
lot so brings together like bringing
together young people maybe like as
young as like 12 years old up until like
maybe 35 something like that and kind of
like having people live together under
like a big warehouse where they have
different like studio rooms with
production equipment maybe 3d printing
stuff art stuff rock walls gardens all
different types of things in this
community place for tinkering and for
playing and engineering and creative
work and so creative warehouse
potentially Island well gonna fill
sports stadiums with curious
intellectuals for full day
multidisciplinary events meditation
science comedy all types of cool things
like that these are all ideas and and
it's really hard in the lifetime to be
able to bring forth all of them and so
we'll see what it ends up evolving into
but but one thing I know that I feel
really good about is that I kind of like
being in a state of like Perpetual
service I've really realized that like I
really want to be in a state of
perpetual service and and
and they just it also feels really weird
trying to prop up like and I have
mentors that have really been helping me
a lot with this but yeah ego being ego
driven and material driven is not
healthy for one psyche and and being
service driven and being really
connected to the the nice love and
compassion and care is what drives I
think me and yeah it's like bronson
alcott over here you'll have to google
it in terms of getting people engaged in
science it doesn't surprise me you have
people emailing you and say like whoa
like I really got more into that or pick
my college major or like whatever
because I know you know what was I able
to Google picking a major like not a lot
and this stuff is significantly more
engaging getting people weren't
interested in science and technology
ultimately you would hope people would
what you know that the warehouse the
education stuff you're doing now in this
selfless spirit you would hope would
conjure X within people there's at least
a theme well how do you describe that
that's a good question so I do think
that you get to a sense of objective
truth by hearing about science I think
that that can help generate a desire for
kind of like that overview effect that
that understanding of of the unity I
think that it is very possible that
people can gain a scientific
understanding of the interconnectedness
of everything and then realize the
oneness and then have that awareness
shift towards wanting love and
compassion and I think science and
technology help people get to that point
so yeah hopefully hopefully that flower
shirts help us well man yeah the little
little floral for sure for sure
everything is you know long yeah and it
helps a lot because then you know
conversations with people like you I
think we're where you lay out some
really important steps for us I think
get young people are realizing that okay
for the things that dance said to come
to fruition there need to be young
people working on solving those
technical and scientific challenges
along the way artistic challenges and so
that's what hopefully people can take
away from some of the conversation we
had just crossed yeah then thank you so
much for coming on the show for round
two - I love it hello it's so much
hopefully there have been good things
taken away for you guys for tuning in
thank you so much we really appreciate
it we'd love to hear your thoughts on
this era of programmatically generated
everything let us know your thoughts in
the comments below share it with friends
family co-workers on social media let's
get people talking about this and how to
actually get there how to work together
in getting there and our ideas in the
field also support the artists and
entrepreneurs and organizations that you
believe in around the world supports
simulation our links are below help us
doing do awesome things like continue
coming to Cambridge for interviews and
achieving all those other goals we
listed at the end of the episode and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world thank you so
much for tuning in and we will see you
soon peace good job got him
good job hey man